lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
analizar qué propiedades de las formas
se conservan o no al aplicar una o motes
ya a una figura aquí tenemos un
cuadrilátero vamos a aplicar una
potencia con centro en el punto p y
vamos a usar nuestra herramienta de omo
tesis la primera pregunta es se
conservan las coordenadas de los
vértices pausa en el vídeo y traten de
responder a esta pregunta vamos a
responder esta pregunta
experimentalmente aplicamos una o motes
ya cualquiera y vemos que no se
mantienen las coordenadas de estos
vértices el vértice que corresponde a d
no tiene la misma coordenada que el
nuevo punto que lo representa lo mismo
pasa con el nuevo vértice que representa
el vértice
tiene coordenadas diferentes lo mismo
pasa con los vértices b y c sus vértices
correspondientes tienen otras
coordenadas después de realizar una
noticia así pues a realizar una homo
test ya no se conservan las coordenadas
de los vértices regresemos a la forma
original veamos la siguiente pregunta
los segmentos de cada lado del
cuadrilátero después de realizar una
potencia
en la misma recta vamos a aplicar una
potencia para ver qué pasa si
consideramos este punto b prima pues
corresponde al punto b el segmento b
prima se prima no sigue la misma recta
que el segmento bs pero el segmento a
prima de prima si sigue la misma recta
que el segmento a de la razón de esto es
que si dibujamos una recta que contenga
al segmento ade también va a contener al
punto p así que conforme expandimos la
figura este segmento se va a expandir
siguiendo esta misma recta pero esto no
se cumple para los demás segmentos de la
figura ya que el punto p no se encuentra
en la misma recta que estos otros
segmentos aplicamos una o motes ya para
apreciar esto la siguiente pregunta es
las medidas de los ángulos se conservan
parece que si ésta es una de las cosas
que se conservan al aplicar una o motes
ya se conservan las medidas de los
ángulos este ángulo sigue siendo un
ángulo recto la medida del ángulo del
vértice b es la misma que la del ángulo
b prima podemos observar lo mismo en las
medidas de los demás ángulos
la última pregunta es las longitudes de
los lados el perímetro y el área se
conservan podemos ver que si aplicamos
una potencia para expandir el lado que
corresponde a a d es más largo de hecho
si expandimos la figura vemos que todos
los lados se hacen más grandes y si los
lados aumentan entonces también
aumentará el perímetro y el área de la
misma forma 100 cogemos la figura así
todos los lados serán más pequeños así
pues las longitudes de los lados el
perímetro y el área no se conservan al
aplicar una potencia ahora hagamos las
mismas preguntas con otra potencia esto
será interesante porque el centro de la
omt es ya va a coincidir con uno de los
vértices de la figura la vemos aquí en
este caso tenemos el triángulo a de c y
el centro de lado motes ya estará en el
vértice c la primera pregunta es se van
a conservar las coordenadas de los
vértices de la figura aplicamos una o
motes ya y vemos que se conservan las
coordenadas del vértice c pero las
coordenadas de los puntos que
corresponden a los vértices
no se conservan a prima tiene
coordenadas diferentes a las de a y lo
mismo ocurre con be prima tiene
coordenadas diferentes a las de be ahora
nos preguntan si los segmentos de cada
lado del triángulo sigue en la misma
recta algunos sí y algunos no vamos a
fijarnos en los segmentos hace ibc al
aplicar una potencia vemos que el
segmento a prima se prima sigue la misma
recta que el segmento hace al igual que
el segmento b prima se prima que sigue
la misma recta que el segmento bs esto
se debe a que el centro de la noticia el
punto c se encuentra en la recta de
ambos segmentos simplemente estamos
alejando el extremo que no coincide con
el centro de la noticia o si estamos
encogiendo la figura estaremos
encogiendo estos segmentos siguiendo la
misma recta pero algunos segmentos no
siguen la misma recta por ejemplo a
prima de prima no sigue la misma recta
que el segmento ave y se conservan las
medidas de los ángulos como mencionamos
antes las medidas de los ángulos si se
conservan al aplicar una potencia la
medida del ángulo
es la misma al igual que la medida del
ángulo a prima y del ángulo de prima
finalmente podemos ver que al expandir
la figura aumentan las longitudes de los
lados y si en cogemos la figura las
longitudes de los lados van a disminuir
por lo que las longitudes de los lados
no se conservan y si no se conservan
estas longitudes tampoco se van a
conservar el perímetro ni el área de la
figura el área depende del tamaño de los
lados si expandimos la figura el
perímetro aumenta al igual que el área y
si en cogemos la figura disminuyen tanto
el perímetro como el área
nos vemos en otro vídeo